เฮ
[música]
>> [música]
>> เ
>> Olá, pessoal. Tudo bem com vocês? Sejam
muito bem-vindos e muito bem-vindas a
esse encontro maravilhoso de dia de
feriado. Cadê nossa prova está se
aproximando e a gente tá entrando hoje
no último encontro da nossa jornada de
direito civil. aqui lindamente, né? Eu
quero mandar inclusive um beijo para
todo mundo que tá aí ao vivo
acompanhando a gente. Eu subi o horário,
vou prender esse cabelo direito aqui que
eu tô com cabelo todo esfulanzado pro
alto. A gente subiu o horário, tá, da
aula. A aula ia ser meio-dia, mas como
hoje é feriado, eu falei: "Não, vamos
subir um pouquinho pra gente já eh ter
logo a aula e se livrar, né, e poder
tirar um descansozinho aí no feriado.
Por isso que a gente subiu o nosso
horário." Mas é sobre, gente. Beijo para
você que tá aí ao vivo acompanhando a
gente.
Eh, hoje a gente vai estudar a parte
geral.
muita coisa da parte geral eh decorre,
aliás, é
precedente importante paraa parte
específica. Então, muita coisa você já
sabe, porque a gente já conversou e hoje
a gente vai fazer um juízo de
recordação, de lembrança dessa parte
geral. E a gente vai começar do começo.
Bora no nosso material começar
desenhando. E vou dizer uma coisa para
você.
Se você participar da nossa revisão de
vésper para amanhã, vou dizer uma coisa.
Vou dizer uma coisa. Vai ganhar um
material tão lindo de direito civil, um
caderno lindo, lindo, lindo, lindo de
direito civil que nem você vai acreditar
que você ganhou.
Seguinte, é,
se liga no esquema e é sobre, tá? Vamos
lá, então. De olho no nosso material.
Vamos estudar agora aqui a parte geral,
gente. Eh, uma coisa que cai na prova
bastante é sobre
incapacidade, né? E aí eu inicio essa
parte perguntando para você
quem são?
Vou botar aqui, ó, quem são?
Os incapazes.
Que que você me diz? E aí, quem são
esses incapazes?
Quem são? Me fala. Ah, professora, eu
lembro que é a pessoa
eh
com deficiência.
Deixa eu te falar, para com isso. Pessoa
com deficiência hoje, depois do Estatuto
da Pessoa com deficiência, você olha, a
pessoa com deficiência, ela é
completamente capaz. Ela pode praticar
atos da vida civil, pode. Ela pode ter
filhos, pode. Ela pode decidir sobre a
vida dela, pode tranquilamente. Então,
muito, muito cuidado. pessoa,
a pessoa com deficiência, estou mexendo
no material, a pessoa com deficiência
ela é completamente
capaz
até que ela não consiga manifestar
vontade. Se ela não conseguir manifestar
vontade, aí são outros 500. Aí ela pode
ser considerada incapaz, não pela
deficiência, mas simplesmente
porque não manifesta vontade. E onde que
a gente encontra essa questão? No artigo
terceiro do Código Civil. O artigo
terceiro do Código Civil traz os
absolutamente e o artigo quarto o
relativamente. Vamos aqui no nosso
material que eu já coloquei para você
aqui, ó. Quem são os incapazes? Nós
temos dois tipos de incapazes. Nós vamos
ter os, vou botar de rosa, absolutamente
incapazes, que são esses
trazidos aqui
no artigo terceiro do Código Civil. E
nós temos os
relativamente incapazes, que são esses
aqui trazidos no artigo terceiro do no
artigo quto do Código Civil, perdão.
Então, artigo terceiro e artigo quto do
Código Civil. Quem é depois do Estatuto
da Pessoa com Deficiência o único
absolutamente incapaz, o menor de 16
anos?
E quem são os relativamente incapazes?
Os de 16 a 18 anos, que é essa galerinha
aqui, ó. Vamos grifar os de 16 a 18
anos, que são os relativamente
incapazes, os menores púlberes, os
ébrios habituais, que são os alcistas,
os viciados em tóxico, né? os drogados,
termo horroroso, mas para exemplificar,
aqueles que, seja por uma causa
transitória, seja por uma causa
permanente,
não puderem manifestar vontade.
Então, quem não consegue manifestar à
vontade porque tá sobre o efeito de um
medicamento ou porque tá em coma, ou
porque tá numa anestesia, ou porque tem
algum problema, né, uma demência, por
exemplo, e não consegue manifestar
vontade, será considerado relativamente
incapaz. E os e os pródigos, tá? Os
pródigos são os gastadores compulsivos.
Pois muito que bem, nesse ponto eu quero
que você observe que esses são os
incapazes. Mas duas perguntas são
importantes pra gente. Primeiro, o
incapaz,
olha isso, o incapaz,
ele pode praticar ato da vida civil.
Vamos lá. Eles podem
praticar
atos da vida civil. Que que você me diz?
E um outro ponto que eu quero ressaltar
com você, pessoa com deficiência é
capaz. Vou colocar bem aqui, ó,
bonitinho para você não errar. Atenção,
atenção.
Pessoa com deficiência
é é capaz. Se ela não conseguir
manifestar vontade, ela será incapaz por
esse fundamento aqui, ó. Por esse
fundamento aqui. Quem por causa
transitória ou permanente não manifesta
vontade. No mais, pessoa com deficiência
é é capaz. OK.
pessoa com deficiência é capaz. Então,
tá bom, professora.
Eh,
entendi. Mas assim,
eles podem assinar contrato, eles podem
ter uma conta no Banco do Brasil, por
exemplo, eles podem praticar atos da
vida civil. Qual que é a resposta dessa
pergunta? A resposta é sim.
Sim. Sim. Eles podem, só que desde que
desde que eles estejam devidamente
repreentados
devidamente representados.
Tá
bom? Nesse ponto, nesse aspecto, eu
quero te perguntar quem é que representa
essas pessoas.
Nós temos três possibilidades. Quem é
que lembra?
Os pais,
os tutores
e os curadores.
Quando é que a gente vai ter os pais?
Os pais representam os filhos
menores,
os filhos
menores
em virtude do chamado poder
familiar,
aquele poder que os pais possuem
automaticamente simplesmente por serem
pais.
O poder familiar é o poder que esses
pais possuem de gestão da vida dos seus
filhos menores. Filho maior não tem
sobre ele o poder familiar dos pais. O
poder familiar, evidentemente, chega ao
fim. E chega ao fim como, Roberta? Chega
ao fim por meio da maioridade dos
filhos, a emancipação dos filhos. chega
ao fim, por exemplo, pela morte dos
pais, pela morte dos filhos, ou também
pode chegar ao fim pela destituição do
poder familiar, ou seja, o pai e ou a
mãe que perdem o poder familiar em
virtude, por exemplo, de atos eh
praticados
contra os filhos. abandono,
a
questão do menino Henry Borel, que é a
violência, né, praticada em relação aos
filhos. E também todas essas
possibilidades estão no 1638
do Código Civil e também desde 2018 a
prática de violência doméstica em face
da mãe dos filhos faz com que o pai
perca o poder familiar sobre aqueles
filhos menores, né? a gente tem uma
constante evolução legislativa no
sentido de coibir e apertar o cerco cada
vez mais para o agressor de mulheres,
né? Então, nesse ponto, nós vamos ter a
possibilidade de perda do poder
familiar.
Perde-se o poder familiar, o pai ou a
mãe que pratica a violência doméstica em
face dos filhos. Bom, seguindo o bonde,
quando esse poder familiar, presta
atenção agora, chega ao fim,
mas não pela maioridade ou pela morte
dos filhos ou emancipação, quando ele
chega ao fim
pela morte dos pais
ou pela perda
do poder familiar por parte desses pais,
Entra em cena
uma outra criatura que é o tutor. O
tutor não coexiste,
não coexiste com o poder familiar, tá? O
tutor ele cuida
dos menores,
ele cuida dos menores que estejam
desprovidos, desprotegidos
por conta da ausência do poder familiar,
ou porque os pais morreram ou porque
houve a perda do poder familiar. Então,
a gente chama os tutores. Os tutores
são designados para os menores
por decisão judicial.
Tá? E quando a gente fala de uma pessoa
que é maior,
maior,
incapaz,
a gente chama os curadores,
os maiores que não manifestam vontade. A
gente vai ter uma ação de interdição e
também por uma decisão judicial.
uma decisão judicial, a gente chama uma
pessoa para tomar conta desse maior.
Então, para os menores, a gente tem os
pais
ou a gente tem quem?
os tutores. Agora, para os maiores,
para os maiores
nós temos os curadores. Uma dica que eu
quero te dar, ao completar 18 anos, a
capacidade se presume, tá? Então,
imagina que uma pessoa com 17 anos já é
viciada em tóxico. A gente viu que o
toxicômano
ele é relativamente incapaz. Então, esse
menino com 17 anos já é viciado
intóxico. Que que a gente vai fazer? A
gente vai observar que ao completar 18
anos, essa pessoa se torna capaz. Ao
completar 18 anos, essa pessoa é capaz.
A capacidade se presume. Se a mãe fala
assim: "Poxa, meu filho,
antes dos 18 eu cuidava dele porque ele
é incapaz.
Agora com 18 ele passa a ser capaz. Que
que eu vou fazer? Aí a mãe pode
interditar o filho com a ação de
interdição ou também chamada ação de
curatela dos interditos e pedir para ser
nomeada curadora desse filho. Porque
completou 18 anos. A emancipação ela se
presume, tá? Ela se presume. Tudo bem?
Então, dá uma olhada no material. Aqui
nós temos quem pode representar.
Lembrando que o absolutamente incapaz
ele é literalmente representado.
O relativamente ele é assistido, tá?
Então a representação para o
absolutamente é na modalidade
representação e para o relativamente é
na modalidade assistência.
Dica do coração, gente, dá o print nessa
tela aí. Olha só. Dica categoria
do coração.
Do coração que eu vou até botar uma
caneta mais grossa aqui. Pessoa com
deficiência
é
capaz.
Você não vai errar isso na sua prova.
Pessoa com deficiência é capaz. Pessoa
com deficiência é
capaz.
Uai, professora,
ela pode tudo. Pode tudo. Pessoa com
deficiência é capaz. Agora,
agora
deixa eu te contar uma história.
Se essa pessoa com deficiência,
se essa pessoa com deficiência,
se ela não
manifestar
vontade,
se ela não manifestar vontade,
ela será considerada
relativamente
incapaz.
essa criatura
do inciso 3,
do inciso 3 do artigo quº que diz:
"Quem
por causa transitória ou permanente não
manifestar vontade será considerada
relativamente incapaz,
aí essa pessoa estará sujeita a
cura. Ela.
Tudo bem? Agora,
a pessoa com deficiência é capaz. E
sendo capaz,
pode ser que ela precise
apenas e tão somente de uma
ajuda,
de um apoio.
Ou seja, ela é capaz, mas precisa de um
apoio, de uma ajuda.
Nesse caso, a gente pode ter
a chamada
tomada
de decisão
apoiada,
a chamada
TDA,
tomada de decisão apoiada. Não é uma
curatela e não se confunde com curatela.
A tomada de decisão apoiada é uma
ferramenta
de ajuda para pessoas maiores capazes
que não são, então, portanto, incapazes
e precisam apenas e tão somente de um
auxílio, de um apoio. Caiu uma vez na
prova assim, João com síndrome de Dal.
Como a questão não falava que ele não
conseguia manifestar vontade, então é
porque ele era considerado o quê? Capaz.
João com síndrome de Dal tinha o apoio
dos seus pais por decisão judicial, ou
seja, ele tinha a tomada de decisão
apoiada. Tomada de decisão apoiada
consta no artigo 1000
A. Tá? 1783A.
A tomada de decisão apoiada vai
acontecer
nas situações de apenas necessidade de
um apoio, mas também é judicial,
tá? Também é judicial. O apoiador pode
assinar contrato junto com o apoiado. Tá
bom? Tudo bem?
Sabe esse pessoal aqui, ó, que a gente
comentou? Os relativamente incapazes,
quem são?
os maiores de 16, menores de 18,
habituais e toxicômanos,
quem não manifesta vontade por por
situação transitória permanente e os
pródigos. Sabe essa criaturinha aqui
maior
de 16 e menor de 18? Vamos falar dele.
Essa criatura, ela é o quê?
A gente acabou de falar dela. Essa
criatura aqui,
os maiores de 16
e menores de 18 anos.
Esse sujeito, como a gente viu, ele é
considerado o quê? Relativamente
incapaz.
Ele tem mais de 16.
Ele tem entre 16
e 18 anos.
Nós chamamos essa criaturinha
de menor
púbere,
tá? menor públ.
Conforme a gente acabou de conversar,
quando essa criatura quer praticar um
ato, ele tem que praticar o ato por meio
do seu eh assistente, né, que serão os
pais ou os tutores. A minha pergunta é,
então vamos colocar aqui via de regra,
né? Vamos colocar aqui, ó, esse essa
criatura
via de regra, ou seja,
via de regra, para
praticar
atos. É, é exatamente o que a gente
acabou de falar. Para praticar atos,
ele deverá
ser
representado
reprentado
na modalidade
assistência
por seus
pais
ou seus tutores.
os seus pais ou seus tutores. Ai,
professora, tá bom, entendi. Já, já
repetiu demais. Só que tem um ponto.
Será que tem algum ato que essa criatura
aqui
possa praticar
sem o representante?
o representante, porque se ele pratica
os atos sem o representante,
esses atos serão, sabe o quê?
Anuláveis.
Agora, será que tem algum ato que ele
pratica sem o representante e este ato
ainda assim seja válido? Já caiu em
prova também. Será que tem algum ato que
ele pratica sem o representante este ato
seja válido? Sim. Nós temos três
possibilidades.
Três, ele pode ser testemunha,
acredita?
Ele pode
aceitar
contrato
de mandato
e ele pode fazer o próprio testamento.
Das mais prováveis de prova, ser
testemunha e fazer o próprio testamento.
Então, a pessoa com 16 anos, ele pode
categoricamente
ir no cartório e fazer o próprio
testamento de boa, de boa.
Ele pode ir no cartório, fazer o próprio
testamento de boa, de boa, tá? Isso já
caiu em prova também. O menino foi no
cartório com 16 anos, ele não era
emancipado. Depois os pais emanciparam,
mas ele fez o o testamento com 16 anos.
Esse testamento é válido? Com toda
certeza, porque a lei estabelece, o
Código Civil estabelece que a capacidade
para testar acontece aos 16 anos, tá? Do
mesmo jeito que eu coloquei aqui para
você que via de regra a os atos
praticados pelo relativamente incapaz
sem o representante nesse caso aqui de
maior de 16 a 18 é anulável. Só para
ficar bem bonitinho aqui, eu quero
consignar com você que o incapaz,
só para ficar bem claro aqui no nosso
material, o incapaz
para que o ato dele seja válido,
para que o ato dele seja válido, ele tem
que praticar este ato.
com o seu representante,
que será
pai, mãe, né, tutor, curador. Então, o
ato do incapaz
para ser um ato válido, ele precisa ter
a prática desse ato ao lado do seu
representante.
Tudo bem? ao lado do seu representante.
Agora, a falta do representante
gera um vício,
gera um vício. Que vício? Depende se for
um absolutamente incapaz, se for um
relativamente incapaz.
Em sendo um absolutamente incapaz, o
problema gerado é a nulidade.
O ato é nulo.
Artigo
166, inciso 1.
Em se tratando de relativamente,
o ato é
anulável.
artigo 171, inciso 1, tá bom? Então,
muito cuidado com essa questão do vício,
tá? Dá o print nessa tela. Aí a gente
sabe também que emancipação é um tema
muito recorrente de prova, muito
categoria também de prova. Profe, como
que fica essa história da emancipação?
Vamos lá.
A emancipação
é a antecipação da capacidade de fato,
né? Eu tenho aqui
nesse tema a
como é que fala? a antecipação da
aquisição da capacidade civil plena, que
acontece com a capacidade de fato.
Então, quais são as formas de
emancipação que nós temos?
Nós sabemos que a banca ama cobrar isso
aqui.
Ama cobrar. E quais são essas formas?
Vamos lá.
São três formes.
Eu tenho a emancipação
voluntária.
Aqui eu quero sua ajuda, tá? Eu tenho a
emancipação
judicial.
e a emancipação
legal.
três formas diferentes
de emancipação.
Voluntária,
judicial,
legal.
voluntária é aquela modalidade
concedida
pelos pais
direto no cartório.
Quando a criatura já tem 16 anos de
idade,
não precisa de homologação judicial,
então independe
homologação
judicial
e é em caráter irrevogável.
Então, os pais vão direto no cartório,
emancipa a criatura lá
direto por escritura pública e vão ser
felizes. É um ato que não se volta
atrás, tá? Ele é exatamente
agora capaz.
Perguntas interessantes de prova.
Eh, quando os pais emancipam
voluntariamente seus filhos no cartório,
e esta emancipação depende da
homologação do juiz para produzir
efeitos? Não, não depende da homologação
do juiz para produzir efeitos. Os pais
deixam de pagar alimentos pros filhos?
Não, também não. Não deixa de pagar
alimentos pro filho, tá?
Os pais podem continuar mandando na vida
dos filhos? Não, mas os pais continuam
responsáveis pelos atos praticados pelo
filho? Sim, até os 18 anos. Porque vai
que aquele menino é um demônio e eu tô
emancipando o menino porque eu não quero
mais me responsabilizar pelos atos
praticados por ele. Não tem como abrir
mão da responsabilidade.
Outro ponto que já caiu em prova várias
vezes, quando o menor, acabei de te
falar, não tem sobre ele o poder
familiar dos pais, a gente chama quem?
Fala para mim. Os tutores. Muito bem. A
gente chama os tutores.
Tutor não emancipa tutelado. Repita
junto comigo. Tutor não emancipa
tutelado. Tutor não emancipa tutelado.
Tutor não emancipa tutelado. Tutor não
emancipa tutelado. Quando o menor é
tutelado, a emancipação é concedida pelo
juiz
por meio de uma sentença
num procedimento judicial
de emancipação,
quando a criatura já tenha também 16
anos
ouvido
o tutor no processo e o Ministério
Público. Se eu tô falando de tutô é
porque não tem os pais,
tá? Então aqui nós vamos ter
tudo bonitinho, bonitinho.
A emancipação legal, a emancipação legal
ela vai acontecer pelas hipóteses da
lei.
E aí o que que a gente vai ter aqui? Nós
vamos ter o seguinte, eh, as hipóteses
previstas no artigo 5º, nós vamos ter
casamento.
Com quantos anos a criatura pode se
casar?
16 anos é a idade núbil.
16 anos é a idade Núbio.
Lembre-se da regra do artigo 1520
que diz: "Em nenhum caso será possível o
casamento de quem não atingiu a idade
Núbio." Então, em nenhum caso será
permitido o casamento de quem não tem
alcançado os 16 anos.
antes podia para evitar pena de estupro
e em caso de gravidez isso não acontece
mais. Tá? Ainda bem, né?
Eh, além do casamento, ah, casou com 16
anos, emancipou, divorciou com 17.
Me fala, casou com 16,
emancipou, divorciou com 17. Volta ou
não volta? ser incapaz não volta. Claro
que não. Óbvio que não, né?
Isso aqui também já caiu em prova. O
menino casou com 16 anos. A questão da
prova era assim: "O menino casou com 16
anos, não sei quê, não sei que lá, e
ficou indignado, descobriu um inferno na
terra, divorciou com 17, comprou uma
passagem para ir cuidar eh
para ir cuidar
da vida, da do do emocional, do
psicológico, tava #chateadinho.
falar,
vai viajar, não precisa dos pais para
viajar, ele tá emancipado.
Além disso,
nós também temos a emancipação legal
por, opa, ficou de azul.
colação
de grau
em curso
superior.
Não é aprovação no vestibular, não é
aprovação no vestibulinho,
tá? é colação de grau em curso superior
também, não é curso técnico.
Além disso,
exercício
de emprego
público
efetivo,
aquela galera lá, né, do
seletista do concurso, que às vezes o
concurso abre ali para quem já tem 16
anos, porque já pode celebrar relação de
trabalho, enfim.
e também por estabelecimento
civil ou comercial, não me pergunte a
diferença,
ou por relação de emprego,
a criatura já tenha 16 anos
e tenha economia
economia
própria,
ou seja, ela se sustenta. Imagina então
uma questão que caiu no concurso do TJ
DFT pela banca FGV.
Foi assim, Joãozinho tinha um canal no
YouTube e ele ganhava já um bom dinheiro
no canal dele do YouTube dando aulas de
história. E aí o canal era super
movimentado, ele tinha uma boa receita,
eh, de modo que aquilo poderia
configurar a economia própria dele. Ele
contava com 15 anos de idade. A banca
queria saber se ele estaria emancipado.
Gente, não por conta da idade, não é só
a economia própria. É um somatório.
Idade e economia própria. 16 anos e
economia própria. Tá bom?
Tudo bem? Beleza. Show de bola. Dá uma
olhada aqui. Vamos lá.
Imagina você que eu tenho mudando aqui
completamente assunto.
Completamente.
Imagina você
que eu tenho
uma
Maria. Vamos botar aqui Maria. Vamos lá.
Maria é dona de uma fazenda.
Vamos mudar de assunto total real
oficial. Maria, eu nem ia falar disso
aqui, não sei por. Então vamos lá. Maria
é proprietária.
Vamos desenhar Maria para ficar mais
bonitinho. Bora.
Maria
é proprietária
proprietária
de uma fazenda,
tá?
O João,
o João
ocupa essa fazenda. Olha essa história.
O João ocupa essa fazenda.
Se o João ocupa essa fazenda, ele é o
quê? possuidor.
O João é o possuidor.
Pois muito que bem. Tá aqui a fazenda.
Negócio aqui.
Na estrutura original da fazenda tinha
uma casa,
tinha uma casa aqui bem bonitinha.
Que que o João fez
em vermelho? O João fez uma série de
benfeitorias.
Ele fez um muro de contenção aqui porque
a o morro lá tava ameaçando desmoronar.
Ele reformou o telhado porque tava dando
goteira.
Ele fez um caminho de saída pra fazenda
aqui pavimentado, né? Ele fez aqui, ó,
bem bonitinho aqui de tijolinho.
Ele construiu uma piscina gigantesca.
Ele plantou várias árvores
frutíferas.
Ele fez um curral aqui para colocar os
animais,
tá? Ele construiu uma casinha aqui pro
caseiro,
bem bonitinha também.
Ele fez um monte de benfeitoria.
Professora,
onde você quer chegar? Primeiro eu quero
que você me fale o que são benfeitorias.
Eu tenho três tipos de benfeitorias.
Eu tenho as chamadas
benfeitorias
úteis,
necessárias.
e
voluptuárias.
Se lembra? Benfeitorias úteis,
necessárias e voluptuárias. Para que que
serve uma benfeitoria útil, né? Útil ou
não. Para que que serve uma benfeitoria
útil? é aquela benfeitoria que torna o
bem, né, mais agradável, aumenta o seu
uso. É uma benfeitoria. Por exemplo, eu
tenho uma casa que tem três banheiros,
eu vou lá e faço um quarto banheiro. Eu
tenho uma casa que tem um
uma estrutura já boa. Tem lá o piso de
cerâmica. Eu troco o piso de cerâmica
por um piso de porcelanato. É uma
benfeitoria útil.
A benfeitoria necessária serve para
conservação do bem.
Tá dando infiltração no telhado, eu
troco o telhado. Isso é uma benfeitoria
o quê, pessoal? uma benfeitoria
necessária.
Eh, a benfeitoria voluptuária é aquela
benfeitoria para lazer, deleite,
afmoseamento, embelezamento. Eu tenho um
jardim e aí eu vou lá e coloco aquela
fonte linda de do anjinho fazendo xixi
na água.
Eu tenho uma casa, eu vou lá e construo
uma piscina. Eu sempre tenho que
analisar a benfeitoria de maneira
casística.
Porque veja, dentro de uma casa a
piscina é voluptuária, mas numa escola
de natação, uma piscina a mais, ela é o
quê? Útil. Então eu tenho que analisar
casuisticamente
o que a gente vai conversar aqui agora.
Tem a incidência do Código Civil, não
tem a incidência da lei do inquilinato,
que é a 8245.
Lá na lei do inquilinato, o locatário
pode fazer benfeitoria necessária,
independentemente
de consentimento do locador, mas
benfeitoria útil ele só pode fazer com
consentimento e voluptuar ele não pode
fazer.
Imagina aqui que o menino,
o João, que é o possuidor desse dessa,
desse negócio aqui da fazenda da Maria,
ele foi lá e fez benfeitorias.
Ele fez benfeitorias úteis, ele fez
necessárias e ele fez voluptuárias.
Vamos identificar o muro de contenção, a
reforma no telhado necessária, né? A
piscina voluptuária,
a passagem aqui pavimentada para não
ficar dando terra, uma benfeitoria útil.
Esse possuidor, quando ele for devolver
o imóvel paraa Maria, ele tem que ser
indenizado.
Ele tem que ser indenizado. O que que
você me diz aqui?
Depende, depende e depende se ele tá de
boa fé ou se ele tá de má fé. Aqui eu
torno a explicar para você o óbvio.
Possuidor de mafé não é a pessoa
demoníaca do cão, não. Possuidor de
mafé, vou botar aqui, ó, de verde.
É aquela pessoa que não ignora vícios,
tá? é a pessoa que não ignora vícios.
Então, se eu, o João, tá ocupando a
fazenda, que ele sabe que ele não tem
legitimidade para est ali, ele é um
possuidor de má fé. Minha pergunta é: o
possuidor de boa fé, ele pode fazer
benfeitorias?
Pode. O de mafé pode também? Pode,
porque o que define a benfeitoria não é
quem faz, é o que é feito. E qualquer um
pode fazer qualquer tipo de benfeitoria.
Então, o possuidor de boa fé pode fazer
uma benfeitoria necessária,
uma benfeitoria útil ou também uma
voluptuária. Tranquilo.
O possuidor de mafé pode fazer uma
necessária, uma útil e uma voluptuária
também. A minha pergunta é: quando a
Maria for pegar de volta esse bem, ela
tem que indenizar o possuidor?
Se o cara tiver de boa fé, indeniza
tudo.
Indeniza tudo. Tudo. Deixa eu ver se eu
consigo baixar um negócio aqui,
né? Porque assim,
indeniza tudo. Não posso deixar ninguém
enriquecer as custas dos outros. O
código veda expressamente enriquecimento
sem causa.
Presta atenção.
Bemfeitoria necessária.
Indeniza. Útil. indeniza, voluptuária,
indeniza. Se for
o sujeito de máfé pela necessária
indeniza,
pela útil e pela voluptuária
não indeniza nada.
Então, a benfeitoria,
a benfeitoria
necessária
e a útil, ele indeniza. Pera aí, deixa
eu diminuir essa linha aqui. A
benfeitoria necessária
e a útil,
ele indeniza.
E se a Maria não quiser pagar, ele
exerce o direito de quê? De retenção. O
que que significa a retenção? A retenção
é exatamente ele fecha o bem e a Maria
não entra enquanto não indenizar.
Lembra disso? Regrinha básica do
coração.
A benfeitoria voluptuária,
se a Maria não quiser pagar,
tem o levantamento, ou seja, ele ranca e
leva com ele desde que não abalha a
estrutura do imóvel, mas não tem o
direito de retenção.
A benfeitoria necessária pelo possuidor
de Mafé
é
exatamente
uma situação
de evitar o enriquecimento sem causa.
Porque veja, você tava dando gotejamento
no telhado, ele foi lá e trocou o
telhado. Ainda que ele esteja de mafé,
ele meio que fez um favor, né? Ele fez
um favor. Então, benfeitoria
necessária pelo possuidor de uma fé é
indenizado, mas tem um detalhe, ele não
tem direito de
retenção.
Ele não tem direito de retenção. OK,
professor? E qual vai ser o valor que eu
vou pagar
aqui?
O valor atual
aqui, o valor atual
ou o valor de custo é o que for
menor. Eu quero pagar o mais barato, tá?
Por quê? Porque o cara tá de má fé.
Então, muito cuidado. A banca gosta de
cobrar essas regras e isso aqui são
regras de posse
e gosta de cobrar o conceito das
benfeitorias. se são úteis, se são
necessárias, se são voluptuárias. Tudo
bem?
Dá o print nessa tela, segue aqui
comigo. Vamos conversar agora de um
outro ponto que também é muito festejado
em prova e que são cobradas questões
casísticas, né?
que é sobre,
eu esqueci que que eu fal, ah, lembrei,
que é sobre negócio jurídico lá do
artigo 104 até o artigo 180
4. 104 a 184. Vamos lá. Olha só,
quando a gente fala de negócio jurídico,
basicamente estamos falando de dois
aspectos:
negócio
jurídico.
Estamos falando de dois aspectos.
Dois aspectos. Estamos falando de
contratos
e estamos falando de testamentos,
que na aula de sucessões a gente já
conversou.
Contrato, contrato e testamento. Você
não pode pensar nos contratos como sendo
apenas aquelas manifestações previstas
no Código Civil como sendo contratos.
Não. Contrato é toda manifestação de
vontade
com finalidade negocial. Se eu tô
fazendo um pacto antenupcial no
casamento, aquilo é uma modalidade
especial de contrato. Por isso que é um
negócio jurídico. Então, eu falo de
contratos e falo de testamentos, mas no
final das contas eu estou falando da
vontade humana.
Vontade humana com finalidade.
Que bosta.
Finalidade
negocial,
tá? Finalidade negocial. Então é sempre
a vontade humana com a finalidade
negocial.
Profe, o que que eu tenho que lembrar?
Você tem que lembrar da nossa
queridíssima escada ponteana, que não é
uma escada numa ponte, mas é a nossa
escada pensada, idealizada pelo nosso
glorioso
pai da teoria geral dos fatos, Pontes de
Miranda. Então, eu preciso de quê? Eu
preciso de
existência,
validade
e o quê? E
o que que eu preciso para verificar
se é válido ou não que ele exista?
Ah, professor, então para saber, para
tentar analisar se o negócio é válido ou
não, eu preciso que tenha validade. Sim.
Para verificar se ele produz efeitos, eu
não tenho que ter a validade, eu tenho
que ter a existência. Olha para mim. É
possível que o negócio jurídico não seja
válido, não seja válido, mas produza
efeitos. Sim, imagina um casamento entre
irmãos, que é um casamento nulo, que
durou 50 anos, mas o negócio jurídico
nulo nunca se torna válido. Nunca se
torna válido. Então, passou 50 anos esse
casamento num regime de comunhão
universal de bens com 10 filhos,
que por sua vez possuem 10 netos cada
um. Veja, é um casamento nulo, mas que
com certeza produziu efeitos.
E eu também não posso vincular a
validade com a produção de efeitos. Eu
não posso fazer isso porque não
significa que é válido, que produz
efeito. Não, porque é válido, com
certeza vai produzir efeito. Nani, não.
Pode ser que o negócio seja válido e não
produza efeitos. Aqui eu entro com você
pacto antenupcial. Olha só. Olha só.
Então, só para ficar bonitinho aqui no
nosso material, eu posso ter um negócio
jurídico existente.
Pera aí, deixa eu anotar. Eu posso ter
um negócio jurídico existente,
válido e eficaz. Posso, eu posso ter um
negócio jurídico existente,
inválido,
inválido e eficaz. Posso, posso ter um
negócio jurídico existente, válido e
ineficaz?
Posso, não tem problema nenhum, porque
uma coisa não vincula a outra. Só que,
gente, para para pensar, vamos aquele
nosso clássico exemplo do pacto
antenupcial. Já já eu volto naquela
naquela tela lá. Vamos lá. Olha isso
aqui,
o exemplo,
o exemplo que já foi cobrado em prova.
O João,
João
queria se casar
com a Maria.
Para tanto, eles fizeram um pacto
antenupcial,
um pacto antenupcial
no cartório por escritura pública,
escolhendo o regime da separação
convencional de bens.
Então nós vamos no nos casar no regime
da separação convencional de bens, tá?
Acabou que o João ficou muito doente e
deu uma pausa nos preparatórios. Ele
ficou 6 meses
internado na UTI.
Quando ele saiu, ele falou: "Maria,
não vamos casar, não. Vamos nos unir
em
união estável
e vamos gastar esse dinheiro que a gente
tinha reservado pra nossa festa com
viagem.
Tudo bem? Isso aqui aconteceu em 2015.
Quando foi em 2026,
o João chegou para Maria e falou:
"Maria,
não pense que lhe quero mal, apenas não
te quero mais".
Lembra do nosso clássico exemplo?
Veja, eles fizeram um pacto antenupcial
no cartório,
escolhendo o regime da separação
convencional de bens.
Olha que sensacional.
Separação convencional de bens. Maria e
João não casaram
e como eles não casaram, foram viver uma
união estável.
Que que rolou? Rolou que
o João em 2006
falou para Maria: "Maria, não pense que
lhe quero mal, apenas não te quero
mais". O artigo 1653,
ele é o artigo do pacto antinupicial e
ele diz o seguinte: "Curte essa parada".
Olha
o que que ele diz aqui.
Olha isso. É nulo,
professora, pelo amor de Deus. É nulo o
pacto antenopcial se não for feito por
escritura pública. Ele fez por escritura
pública. Fez. Então tá tudo OK. Ele é
válido, viu? Ele é válido.
Ele é válido.
E aí em 2026, quando João vira para
Maria e fala: "Maria, não pense que lhe
quero mal, apenas não te quero mais". A
Maria devolve, né? Olha, meu ex-amor,
só queria que tu soubesses o quanto eu
chorei por ti, mas também agora também
não choro mais. Seguinte, é, como é que
a gente vai resolver a partilha de bens?
O João vira e fala: "Que partilha de
bem?
que partilha de bens, porque eu tenho
aqui na minha mão um documento
feito no cartório e nesse documento tá
escrito aqui, minha querida, pacto
antenupcial,
escolhendo o regime da separação de
bens.
Então o seguinte, é o que vale é o que
tá na minha mão e a gente não tem nada
para partilhar porque tá tudo no meu
nome.
Aí a Maria vira e fala: "Meu querido,
seguinte, é esse, não tem esse negócio
de gentileza aqui, não. Anote o número."
A Maria vira e fala: "Amor, muito
embora, aliás, melhor, meu ex-amor,
muito embora você tenha um pacto
antenupcial na sua mão, feito por
escritura pública, no cartório,
escolhendo o regime da separação de
bens. Então, portanto, este documento é
um documento válido. Eu sinto lhe
informar que
nunca produziu os seus efeitos.
Porque o artigo 1653,
ele é muito claro ao estabelecer que o
pacto antenupcial deve ser feito por
escritura pública
para ser válido. E se não acontecer o
casamento, ele é ineficaz.
Então, como a gente não celebrou o
casamento, meu querido, sinto lhe dizer,
nós vivemos uma união estável. E como a
gente viveu uma união estável, esse
documento, embora seja válido, ele é
ineficais.
E para a união estável, meu querido,
quando a gente não fala abertamente qual
que é o regime de bens num pacto
convivencial,
nós vamos aplicar o regime da comunhão
parcial de bens. E na comunhão parcial
de bens, tudo que estiver, mesmo em nome
de um ou de outro, se foi adquirido
onerosamente na constância da união
estável, deve ser efetivamente
partilhado por dois.
Seguinte, é,
meu querido, aqui não tem esse negócio
de gentileza, não, tá? E é sobre isso.
Então, eu posso sim ter um negócio
jurídico
que
seja inválido e produz efeitos, como eu
posso ter um negócio jurídico que é
válido e não produz efeitos. João,
no final das contas é bem incapaz dele
virar e falar assim: "Ah, não, amor,
desisti.
Você é o amor da minha vida. Você é o
presente de Deus. Eu lembrei aqui, foi
um devaneio da minha cabecinha. A Maria,
ela vai vir para e vai falar assim: "Vai
se ferrar, né, meu querido? Não quer,
quer, quem não quer mais agora sou eu."
E seguinte é: vai me pagar alimentos
porque eu fiquei aqui em casa
trabalhando, cuidando das crianças
enquanto você trabalhava. Agora você vai
me pagar alimentos pelo menos por um ano
para poder retomar minha vida social e
profissional.
E é sobre. Agora vamos lá. O que que eu
preciso para que o negócio jurídico
que eu preciso para que o negócio
jurídico exista?
E o que que eu preciso para que ele seja
válido?
Quem é que lembra? Me ajude aí. Vamos
lá.
Existência
e validade. Que que eu preciso para que
o negócio vai tomando?
Que que eu preciso para que o negócio
jurídico exista? Básico,
vontade.
Que mais?
Agente que emite essa vontade,
objeto
e forma. Forma é o meio pelo qual você
exterioriza a sua vontade, tá? A forma
via de regra é livre.
Eu posso fazer de forma oral, de forma
escrita, por escrito público, escrito
particular. Então, a forma via de regra
é livre. Mas quando eu definir uma
quando a lei definir uma forma
específica, eu tenho que cumprir. Então,
eu tenho vontade,
agente, objeto e forma. A vontade para
que o negócio jurídico seja válido tem
que ser livre
e de boa fé. O agente tem que ser o quê,
produção?
Capaz. O objeto tem que ser lícito,
possível,
determinado ou pelo menos determinável.
E a forma que via de regra é livre,
quando a lei dispuser uma forma
específica, eu tenho o quê? Cumprir.
Vamos lá. O menino de 15 anos de idade,
o menino de 15 anos de idade vendeu a
bicicleta dele para o rapaz de 18. Olha
bem pro material. O menino de 15 anos de
idade vendeu a bicicleta dele por R$
5.000 para o rapaz de 18. Eu quero saber
se esse contrato existe. Para você
definir se ele existe e a banca te der
uma historinha perguntando se ele
existe, você vai ticar os elementos de
existência.
Você vai ticar os elementos de
existência. Eu tive vontade, sim.
A gente sim. Ah, professora, mas o
menino tem 10 anos de idade. Você vai
responder friamente, tá? Eu tenho
agente, sim. Objeto, bicicleta. Sim.
Forma foi verbal? Sim. A vontade foi
livre de boa fé? Foi. O agente é capaz?
Não. Então o negócio é inválido. Eu nem
analiso o resto.
Se eu chego paraa pessoa e falo: "Ou
você transfere o apartamento para mim ou
eu mato seus filhos". A pessoa foi lá e
transferiu o apartamento para mim. Teve
vontade?
Ah, professora, mas teve uma ameaça. Não
importa. Aqui a gente tá analisando
friamente. Teve vontade? Teve. Teve
agente, teve objeto, apartamento, teve
forma, escritura pública, teve a vontade
foi livre, não. Nem analisa o resto ele
é inválido. Quando o negócio jurídico
não existe, ele não existe, ele não é
nada. Agora, quando você viola,
quando você viola os requisitos
de validade, é onde tá o problema.
Porque se você violar os requisitos de
validade, o negócio jurídico ele é
inválido. Ele existe, mas ele é
inválido. E a invalidade ela pode ser de
duas formas:
grave ou pouco grave. Muito grave,
a gente fala que o negócio é
nulo,
pouco grave.
é anuável.
OK. Muito grave, pouco grave.
Professora,
sou eu que defino o que que é muito
grave, o que que é pouco grave? Não é a
lei. E nós temos os casos
os casos de eh
negócio,
os casos de invalidade. Eu quero pegar
um
um quadro que eu fiz na aula para vocês
que ele é muito lindo.
Ele ficou muito lindo. Perfeito.
dois quadros
que eu vou colocar aqui para vocês
agora.
É muito lindinho.
Estão preparados para essa coisa mais
lindeza do mundo?
Vamos lá. Olha aqui.
Então, sou eu que defino, não é a lei.
Olha o quadro dos sonhos.
Olha isso. Eu tenho nulidade absoluta e
nulidade relativa.
A nulidade absoluta é aquela situação
em que eu tenho o negócio jurídico nulo.
Tá acompanhando?
E e
o anulável é a chamada nulidade
relativa. Tanto o nulo tem os seus casos
quanto as suas características.
O anulável tem seus casos e as suas
características.
Quais são as características do negócio
jurídico nulo? ofender interesse
público, não se convalida com o tempo,
não se torna válido pela vontade das
partes,
tá?
Se eu quiser ajuizar uma ação contra a
parte contrária para declarar a
nulidade, cabe ação declaratória de
nulidade, que como é muito grave, pode
ser proposta por qualquer interessado ou
até mesmo pro pelo Ministério Público,
porque ofende o interesse público,
tá?
é imprescritível,
porque o negócio nulo nunca se torna
válido com o tempo. E essa sentença é
declaratória de nulidade. Quando eu falo
de anulabilidade,
eu tenho que ofende interesse
particular,
pode ser convalidada com o tempo ou
convalidada pela vontade das partes.
Torna-se válido com o tempo. Então eu
tenho que agir rápido para pedir o
reconhecimento da anulação.
O juiz não pode conhecer de ofício. Cabe
a ação a anulatória.
Só pode ser promovida pelas partes.
Tem prazo. A sentença é constitutiva
negativa. Agora, quais são os casos?
Quais são os casos? É nulo. Artigo 166.
Negócio jurídico celebrado com
absolutamente incapaz, quando for
ilícito, impossível ou indeterminável o
seu objeto. O motivo determinante comum
a ambas as partes por um motivo ilícito.
Violar a forma prescrita e lei. Eu falei
que a forma via de regra é livre, mas
quando a lei dispuser uma forma eu tenho
que cumprir. quando for preterida alguma
solenidade, quando a houver por objetivo
fraudar lei imperativa,
quando a lei declarar nulo, então
existem outros artigos que fala de
nulidade, ou quando a lei proibir a
prática sem cominar uma sanção. Aí eu
dei o exemplo do 426, que é o pacta
Corvina. Não pode ser objeto de contrato
herança de pessoa viva. Isso aqui já
caiu em prova também. o menino que cede
a futura e eventual herança que ele vai
receber quando o pai dele morrer para o
amigo. Esse contrato é nulo.
E quais são os casos de anulabilidade?
anulabilidade,
nós temos incapacidade relativa do
agente, que a gente conversou agora, ou
por vício decorrente de erro, dolo,
coação, estado de perigo, lesão ou
fraude contra credores. São os casos
aqui de anulabilidade.
Erro, dolo, coação, lesão, estado de
necessidade ou estado de perigo. Olha eu
aqui, ó, falando besteira. Estado de
necessidade é coisa da responsabilidade
civil, lembra? Estado de necessidade é
uma excludente de ilicitude. Estado de
perigo é uma situação específica aqui do
negócio jurídico e fraude contra
credores. Agora, o que muito cai em
prova é a questão da lesão e da do
estado de perigo. E mais do que isso, os
prazos para ação anulatória.
Profe, qual que é o prazo para ação
anulatória? Presta atenção aqui. Prazo
para ação anulatória.
Os casos de anulabilidade, artigo 171,
são aqueles casos celebrados com
relativamente incapaz: erro, dolo,
coação, estado de perigo, lesão e fraude
contra credores. Qual que é o prazo
decadencial de 4 anos? A gente já sabe
que prazo de decadência, se você deixar
passar, você perde o próprio direito.
Então eu coloquei aqui, ó, esse prazo de
4 anos é contado da celebração do
negócio jurídico. Ele é contado da
celebração do negócio jurídico.
Mas para o caso de relativamente incapaz
e coação, que é a ameaça, eu vou contar
o prazo de 4 anos. quando cessar
cessar a incapacidade e a ameaça, tá? E
esse prazo de 4 anos, ele é um prazo de
quê, Brasil? De decadência.
De decadência.
Se a parte não requerer a anulação nesse
prazo de decadência, ela perderá o
direito de anular e o negócio passa a
ser válido. Só que a gente sabe que a
lei pode prever outros casos de
anulabilidade.
A lei pode prever outros casos de
anulabilidade. Quem é que lembra disso?
Muito bem. A lei pode prever outros
casos de anulabilidade. E um dos casos
de exemplo que a gente dá é o 496. O pai
que vende o carro pro filho. O pai pode
vender o carro pro filho, pode, mas ele
precisa do consentimento do cônjuge ou
companheiro dele e dos demais filhos,
sob pena de anulabilidade.
Quando a lei trouxer, olha aqui que
bonitinho, quando a lei dispuser que
determinado ato é anulável sem
estabelecer prazo para pleitear-se a
anulação, será este prazo de 2 anos a
contar da data da conclusão do ato,
tá? a contar da data da conclusão do
ato. Então isso aqui é maravigold,
maravigolde. Pelo amor de Deus, Jorge
Mateus, não erra isso. E professora,
você tá falando aí do exemplo do pai que
quer vender o carro pro filho. Pois
muito que bem. Eu já fiz esse desenho
com vocês aqui na aula, mas eu vou
relembrar novamente. Olha aqui, ó. O pai
pode vender o bem pro filho mediante
consentimento sob pena de anulabilidade.
Doar não precisa de consentimento, mas
já caracteriza logo adiantamento de
legítima. Quando aquele pai morrer, tem
que colacionar. Artigo 2002. Só não vai
precisar colacionar se o pai declarar
que aquele bem saiu da parte disponível.
Artigo 2005. O pai pode trocar o carro
com o carro do filho? Pode precisa de
consentimento. Não, se os valores forem
iguais. Sim, se os valores forem
desiguais. E se não tiver o
consentimento, eu aplico a mesma regra
da compra e venda. O negócio é anulável
no prazo de quanto tempo? 2 anos, tá?
E um dos pontos que sempre cai em prova
é a questão do estado de perigo e da
lesão. Porque no estado de perigo e na
lesão, como a gente viu aqui, ó,
olha,
estado de perigo e lesão são causas de
anulabilidade.
Só que a a diferença entre eles é muito
tênue. Por no estado de perigo, estado
de perigo,
artigo 156.
E na lesão, a banca sempre gosta de
cobrar tentando te confundir com um e
outro, porque o fundamento delas é muito
parecido. É alguém pagando muito, muito
caro por alguma coisa.
No estado de perigo,
alguém paga muito, muito caro e na lesão
também. Mas o fundamento é diferente. No
estado de perigo, alguém paga muito,
muito, muito caro para salvar
a vida.
É aquele clássico exemplo da pessoa que
chega passando mal no hospital, o
hospital atende o plano de saúde daquela
pessoa e a pessoa simplesmente
eh o plano de saúde, o hospital
simplesmente exige um cheque calção.
Você não vai falar: "Ai, volto depois
não, você tá na merda, você tá morrendo,
você vai dar o cheque calção, inclusive
é crime".
E na lesão, a pessoa paga muito, muito,
muito caro por ou inexperiência
na celebração daquele negócio jurídico.
Uma pessoa que vai vender o imóvel, mas
não tem muito conhecimento do mercado
imobiliário e acaba se ferrando
ou por qualquer outra
necessidade
diferente, né? qualquer outra
necessidade diferente de salvar a vida.
Nós temos essas duas situações
descritas
especificamente
nesses dispositivos. E aí eu quero
colocar para você aqui agora. Olha só
que maravigold. No estado de perigo, o
156 diz: "Cumpra, configura-se o estado
de perigo quando alguém premido da
necessidade de salvar-se ou pessoas de
sua família de gravidando conhecido pela
outra parte, a parte sabe que você tá na
merda e ela tem com você um dolo de
aproveitamento. Ela tira vantagem em
cima da sua situação, assumindo uma
obrigação excessivamente onerosa.
Tratando-se de pessoa não pertencente à
família do declarante, o juiz decidirá
segundo as circunstâncias. OK?
Na lesão, a gente tem o seguinte: ocorre
a lesão quando uma pessoa sob premente
necessidade ou por inexperiência se
obriga a prestação manifestamente
desproporcional. Então, manifest
manifesta excessivamente onerosa, estado
de perigo, manifestamente
desproporcional,
lesão ao valor da prestação oposta.
Aprecia-se a desproporção das prestações
segundo os valores vigentes ao tempo em
que foi celebrado o negócio jurídico.
Agora, pensa comigo, óbvio, aqui alguém
tá pagando muito, muito caro. Se a
pessoa tá pagando muito, muito caro e a
pessoa que se que teve a vantagem eh
aceita devolver o excedente ou cobrar só
o razoável, você mantém o negócio
jurídico, porque a intenção é sempre
manter o negócio jurídico. O parágrafo
2º do 157 diz: "Não se decretará a
anulação do negócio se for oferecido o
suplemento suficiente ou se a parte
favorecida concordar com a redução do
proveito. Esse parágrafo segundo se
aplica por analogia ao estado de perigo.
Tudo bem? Certo? Muito cuidado, muito
cuidado com essa parte, tá bom? Muito
cuidado com essa parte porque é uma
parte que é muito cobrada em prova.
Certo, produção? Tudo bem? Belezura.
Coisa mais linda do mundo.
Coisa mais maravilhosa do mundo. Eu
quero ver, eu quero botar para vocês
aqui também um materialzinho aqui.
Deixa eu ver aqui que eu quero só para
colocar aqui, ó.
Ó.
Quero botar um negócio aqui só para
deixar
bonitinho para vocês,
que é o princípio da gravitação
jurídica, O princípio da gravitação
jurídica, ele é aquel aquele princípio
que faz com que o acessório siga o
principal. Quais são os acessórios que
nós temos? Frutos, produtos,
benfeitorias e pertensas. Não esqueça
que as pertenças não seguem o principal,
tá? somente frutos, produtos e
benfeitorias, que são partes
integrantes. Então, quando você se eh
anuncia sua casa para vender, os seus
móveis que estão dentro da casa, que são
as pertences, não seguem automaticamente
a
a coisa principal, só segue se for
expressamente
dentro da proposta e futuramente da
celebração do contrato, tá? Então vamos
dar o print nas telas de hoje. Gente, a
gente falou muita coisa. Nós estudamos
parte geral hoje.
Professora, senhora presidente do DF?
Não, Alexandre, sou vice-presidente. Só
só não é muita coisa, né?
Eh, dá o print nessa tela dos incapazes.
3 2 1.
A questão da pessoa com deficiência, que
nós vimos aqui que é capaz, né? Sendo
capaz, ela pode ter a TDA.
A questão dos de 16 aos 18 anos, que são
os menores púlberes,
tem o representante, o que que ele pode
fazer? ter testemunha, aceitar contrato
de mandato e fazer seu testamento.
Negócio por absolutamente é nulo, por
relativamente anulável sem o
representante.
Emancipação voluntária, judicial ilegal.
Tutor não emancipa tutelado.
Cuidado com a restituição do bem ao
proprietário e o possuidor que fez
bemfeitorias e os tipos de benfeitorias.
úteis, necessárias e voluptuárias.
Negócio jurídico, existência, validade.
Cuidado com o pacto antinupicial. Se eu
faço pacto antinupicial observando um
regime e eu não caso, embora seja
válido, ele não produz efeito. Ele é
válido, mas ele é ineficaz.
Casos de nulidade, características de
nulidade. Casos de anulabilidade,
características de anulabilidade.
A ação anulatória tem prazo decadencial
de 4 anos, contados da celebração do
negócio jurídico, mas em se tratando de
relativamente incapaz, é da data em que
cessar a incapacidade e em se tratando
de coação, é da data em que cessar a
coação.
doação e troca de pai para filho. A
gente já fez esse desenho anteriormente.
Estado de perigo e lesão. Cuidado porque
o fundamento é diferente,
tá? E a questão do princípio da
gravitação jurídica, o acessório segue
principal. Então, se você vende o
principal, o acessório vai. Mas qual o
tipo de acessório que vai? Frutos,
produtos e benfeitorias. Frutos são
aquelas coisas que são renováveis. Por
exemplo, fruto civil. aluguel, juros,
fruto natural, as maçãs da árvore, né?
Os filhotinhos do cachorro, da
cachorrinha,
produtos são as coisas que não se
renovam, as pedras preciosas de uma
mina, argila, petróleo, benfeitorias,
nós falamos úteis, voluptuárias e
necessárias. E as pertenças, que são
bens que são inseridos com
definitividade no móvel ou no imóvel,
não fazendo parte integrante. O aparelho
de GPS no carro é uma pertença, né? O ar
condicionado, a geladeira, o fogão, a
mesa, sua cama, seu sofá são suas
pertenças. Se você aliena o principal, a
pertensa não vai automaticamente. Eu não
posso presumir que a pertensa vai
automaticamente, OK? E é sobre bom
feriado para você.
Amanhã estaremos juntos na nossa revisão
de véspera. Os meus alunos da revisão de
véspera vão receber um caderno impecável
de revisão, coisa mais linda do mundo,
que é o caderno que a gente utiliza para
revisão. Hoje à noite eu já vou mandar
para o pessoal do estúdio já
disponibilizar no no início do link para
vocês. Amanhã vocês têm esse encontro
marcado com os professores aqui do grão
AB. No domingo é a nossa prova e a
partir das 17 horas nós estaremos ao
vivo no canal do grão AB com o gabarito
pós-prova, a percepção dos professores
ali nas questões cobradas. Geralmente a
gente acerta muita questão na revisão de
vésper.
Na segunda-feira nós teremos um grande
lançamento aqui do Gran OAB às 10 horas
da manhã. Você tem esse compromisso
comigo e eu quero que você esteja
presente, tá bom?
Reta final, vai dar certo. Siga firme,
estamos juntos. De repente, tira o
restinho do dia de hoje, que é feriado,
para dar uma descansadinha para você tá
bem amanhã na revisão de véspera, porque
começa é cedo, tá bom? Beijo, beijo para
vocês. Beijo, Willam, lá da região dos
lagos, Giovana,
Lisiane, Ana Carolina, Letícia, Josué,
Alexandre. Beijo para todo mundo que tá
aí ao vivo acompanhando a gente, tá bom?
Até a próxima.
>> [música]